AT SEA OF BLUE SHOEING AT THE
HONOR AND SUPPORT POLICE
OFFICERS WHO WERE UNDER SIEGE I
AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, COPS ARE
BEING DONE DOWN EVERY SINGLE DAY
.
SIX LAW-ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
WERE SHOT IN LESS THAN 48 HOUR
SPREAD TODAY, IN THE ART, THE
NYPD HONORING FALLEN OFFICER
JASON RIVERA WHO WAS MURDERED
EXECUTION STYLE ALONG WITH HIS
PARTNER AFTER THEY WERE AMBUSHE
BUT HAVE FELL IN WITH A MASSIVE
RAP SHEET.
THE CITY'S NEW POLICE
COMMISSIONER SAYING IT'S TIME T
RESPECT POLICE AGAIN AND PUSH
BACK AGAINST THE ANARCHY BEING
UNLEASHED.
>> WAY MAY NOT MATCH THE
SACRIFICE MADE BY JASON, BUT WE
CAN TRY TO MATCH HIS INCREDIBLE
SENSE OF SERVICE.
WE MAY NOT MATCH HIS COURAGE,
BUT WE CAN TRY TO MATCH HIS
PASSION.
THE HORROR THAT TOOK THEIR LIVE
AS AN AFFRONT TO EVERY DECENT
CARING HUMAN BEING IN THIS CITY
AND BEYOND.
THOSE WHO SEEK TO DIM THE
BEACONS OF HOPE ALONG THESE FIV
BOROUGHS, LOOK OUTSIDE, HEAR OU
VOICES, SEE THE PRESENCE IN THI
CATHEDRAL.
THE NYPD WILL NEVER GIVE UP THI
CITY.
>> THE WIDOW OF OFFICER RIVERA
NOT HOLDING BACK AND CALLING OU
RADICAL DISTRICT ATTORNEYS WHO
ARE PUTTING COPS AND THE PEOPLE
THEY PROTECT AT.
>> THE SYSTEM CONTINUES TO FAIL
US.
WE ARE NOT SAFE ANYMORE.
NOT EVEN THE MEMBERS OF THE
SERVICE.
I KNOW YOU ARE TIRED OF THESE
LAWS, ESPECIALLY THE ONES FROM
THE NEW DA.
TODAY WAS A TURNING POINT IN TH
CITY, I'M SURE YOU FELT THAT, I
FELT THAT, PEOPLE OF THE CITY
FELT THAT RIGHT IT'S ABOUT TIME.
I BELIEVE WE ARE GOING TO GO
FORWARD FROM HERE.
YOU BELIEVE THAT?
>> FROM YOUR LIPS TO GOD'S EARS.
LET ME SAY THIS SPEECHES WERE
POWERFUL IN ST. PATRICK'S.
WHEN THE WIDOW OF JASON RIVERA
GOT UP AND TALKED ABOUT HER
HUSBAND BEING TIRED OF THE LOOS
LAWS ESPECIALLY THE DA.
EVERYBODY GAVE HER A STANDING
OVATION.
WE COME WITH THE PUBLIC HAVE
BEEN SILENT IT'S THIS MINORITY
THAT IS JUST SO LOUD THAT THEY
ARE LITERALLY SILENCING THE RES
OF US WHO ARE JUST KIND OF GOIN
ALONG WITH OUR LIVES.
HERE'S THE BOTTOM LINE, IT IS
CRIMINAL PRIVILEGE RIGHT NOW.
THEY'RE IS A WAR ON COPS, YOU'R
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, BUT IT'S TIME
TO END IT.
THE WAY TO END IT IS WITH
GOVERNORS THAT TALK OUT OF BOTH
SIDES OF THEIR MOUTHS.
THE GOVERNOR SAYS ON THE ONE
HAND I'M NOT GOING TO CHANGE TH
BILL LAWS IN WE'RE GOING TO KEE
LETTING THE CRIMINALS OUT, BUT
I'M GOING TO WORK WITH MAYOR
ADAMS.
SHE'S GOT TO GO.
SHE PICKS ONE SIDE OR THE OTHER.
AS FOR WHO THE NEW GOVERNOR IS,
HOPEFULLY WE WILL PUT HIM OUT O
OFFICE.
WE HAVE GOT TO FIND TUNE INTO
THE INDIVIDUAL.
THE JUDGE, THERE IS A PARTICULA
JUDGE WHO CONTINUOUSLY LETS OUT
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE GUN
CRIMES OVER AND OVER, THREE
TIMES LETTING THEM GET OUT WITH
DIFFERENT GUN CRIMES IN THAN
FINALLY HE ENDS UP SHOOTING A
COP.
THESE ARE THE JUDGES THAT HAVE
THE POWER, BUT DON'T USE IT.
IT'S TIME TO FIND TUNE IT
BECAUSE WE'RE ALL GOING TO LOSE.
WE CAN'T SURVIVE IN OUR SOCIETY
WITH THIS CHAOS.
IT IS AS STANDING TURNING POINT
BECAUSE WE CAN BE STRONG AND
UNITED.
THAT BLUELINE IS A LOT BIGGER
THAN YOU THINK.
>> GREG GUTFELD, YOUR THOUGHTS
ON TODAY?
>> THOSE PICTURES WERE AMAZING.
I DO AGREE THAT I THINK IT'S A
TURNING POINT, BUT IF YOU ARE
SURPRISED BY THIS, YOU'RE AN
IDIOT BECAUSE WE ARE IN THIS
MEMORY ERASING INDUSTRY WERE ON
STORY KNOCKS OUT ANOTHER STORY
LIKE YOU'RE PLAYING A GAME OF
POOL.
IT WAS A TWO-YEAR DEMORALIZATIO
OF POLICE CHAMPION BY THE MEDIA
AND THE ACTIVISTS.
THEY'RE WERE SOME PROGRESSIVE
POLICIES AND ANY THEOLOGY THAT
WE WERE IN A PROGRESSIVE SOCIET
AND EVERYTHING HAS TO CHANGE
GRADE YEAR AGO IF YOU TURN ON
CNN OR MSNBC, THEY WOULD PORTRA
THE POLICE AS MS 13 WITH BETTER
UNIFORMS.
SO NOW, YOU LOOK AROUND THE
CHANNELS TODAY AND YOU SEE ON
CNN AND OTHER PLACES, THEY ARE
COVERING THEIR FUNERALS, RIGHT?
BECAUSE NOW COPS ARE GETTING
SHOT LEFT AND RIGHT AND SOME OF
THEM ARE DYING, SO THEY REALIZE
THAT THEY CREATED THE ATMOSPHER
FOR RANDOM VIOLENCE BY BASICALL
NEGATING THE AUTHORITY OF THE
POLICE.
NOW THEY COVER THE FUNERAL
BECAUSE THEY SENSE THE TIDE IS
TURNING IN THEIR COT IN THE
UNDERTOW.
THEY DO DESERVE TO RUN.
THE MEDIA HITS COVERING CRIME
BECAUSE IF IT DOESN'T PERSONALL
INVOLVE THEM, WHY DOES IT MATTER
?
AND THEN IT DOES BURY THEIR OWN
BELIEFS OPEN THE DOOR TO
PROGRESSIVE DISASTERS LIKE THE
NOBEL NO CASH BAIL, AND YOU
DON'T NEED CONTEXT TO COVER
CRIME, YOU ONLY NEED TWO
VARIABLES, VICTIM AND VICTIMIZER
.
THE MEDIA HATES THAT BECAUSE
IT'S TOO EASY.
THEY NEED TO HAVE CONTEXT, WHIC
MEANS ROOT CAUSES AND SYSTEMIC
RACISM, AND HE WAS ABANDONED AS
A CHILD SO SUDDENLY THE CRIMINA
IS DECRIMINALIZED AND THE
POLITICS BECOMES THE ENDGAME.
WE ALREADY COVERED CNN BASICALL
SAYING THAT OUR COVERAGE OF
CRIME WASN'T INSTAGRAM FILTER.
I HOPE THEY SEND HIM TO THE
FUNERALS AND TOOK PICTURES OF
THE MOURNERS IN USE THE CORRECT
INSTAGRAM FILTER WHEN THEY DID
IT MAY BE THE GOT SOME GOOD
RETWEETS OUT OF IT.
>> COAT SO, YOUR WASHINGTON
BENCH, ARE YOU FEELING WHAT IS
GOING ON UP HERE IN NEW YORK?
IS THIS A NEW OR ECCENTRIC THING
?
IT'S THE NATIONAL AND NATIONAL
SITUATION PART.
>> CARJACKINGS IN THE LAST YEAR
IN DC HAVE REACHED RECORD HIGHS
LOOKING LIKE THE BEGINNING OF
2022, THAT TREND IS CONTINUING
UPWARD PARADE ON THURSDAY, FIVE
PEOPLE WERE SHOT AT A HOTEL, ON
OF THEM FATALLY IN WASHINGTON,
DC.
VIOLENT CRIME IS A MAJOR PROBLE
THERE AS WELL.
TO TODAY'S EVENT I WILL SAY THA
THE WIDOW WAS CORRECT WHEN SHE
SAID THAT THE SYSTEM FAILED HIM
BECAUSE IN A POIGNANT SENSE, HI
DEATH IS NOT ONLY THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF HIS KILLER,
BUT WHICH I MEAN AT LEAST A
SMALL PART OF THE BLAME HERE
GOES TO THE CITY INTO ITS
LEADERSHIP.
I'M SOMEBODY WHO USUALLY LOOKS
AT POLICY SOLUTIONS FOR THE
NATION'S BIGGEST PROBLEMS, BUT
FIXING THE POLICY HERE IS ONLY
SMALL PART OF THE SOLUTION.
DECRIMINALIZING VIOLENT CRIME I
A REAL PART OF THE PROBLEM, BUT
YOU WON'T FIX THIS UNTIL YOU GE
AT THE ANTI- POLICE SENTIMENT
THAT IS RUNNING RAMPANT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DO THAT,
BUT IT TAKES ALL OF US MEANING
ALL OF US AMERICANS STANDING
TOGETHER TO TRY TO COMBAT IT.
I THINK IT'S A TALL ORDER, BUT
THINK THAT'S WHERE THE FOCUS
SHOULD GO WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
MOVING FORWARD.
>> WE ALL NEED TO GET INVOLVED.
WE ARE EXPLICIT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE SYSTEM, UNIT MENTIONE
THE NAME OF THE JUDGE, WE KNOW
BRAGG AND THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
'S OFFICE, WE KNOW THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, THE
MAJORITY MAJORITY LEADER AND TH
STATE LEGISLATURE, THEY WRITE
THESE BILL LAWS AND THEY DON'T
REFORM THEM.
WE KNOW WHO THE PEOPLE ARE, THI
HAS TO BE PERSONALIZED.
>> THEY'RE IS NOTHING MORE, MY
HEART GOES OUT TO THE TWO
FAMILIES.
I DO THINK IT'S A TURNING POINT
YOUR HONOR FROM THIS STANDPOINT
AND EVERYBODY'S COMMENTS AROUND
THE TABLE.
THIS WIDOW'S COMMENTS AND HER
WORDS AND THE ENERGY AND PASSIO
THAT SHE SHOWED IS GOING TO BE
SHOWN ALL ACROSS THE STATE.
TO YOUR POINT, JESSE.
THOSE WHO WILLING TO FUND
EFFORTS TO CHANGE COMMUNITIES,
THERE SHOULD BE AN EFFORT FUNDE
RIGHT NOW, LET HER WORDS BE THE
ONLY WORD, TO RECALL ANY DA DOE
DOES NOT IMPLEMENT TOUGH LAWS
PARADE ANY LEGISLATURE WHO DOES
NOT REFORM BILL REFORM.
AND LET THOSE BE THE WORDS TO
REKINDLE ABOUT HOW WE SUPPORT
POLICE OFFICERS.
I THINK EVERY COMMUNITY IN THIS
CITY, BLACK, WHITE, HISPANIC,
ASIAN, ALL WANT TO SUPPORT AND
DO SUPPORT POLICE OFFICERS.
THAT WIDOW'S COMMENTS SHOULD NO
ONLY HELP DO THAT, BUT THE GUN
THAT KILLED THOSE TWO OFFICERS
WITH THE GHOST COMES FROM
PHILADELPHIA.
WE SHOULD FIGURE OUT WAYS TO
ENACT HER NOT ONLY DO WE NEED
ACTIVISTS WHO WANT TO REFORM
POLICE DEPARTMENTS, WE HAVE TO
SUPPORT OUR COPS FIRST BEFORE W
CAN DO ANY OF THIS.
I HOPE THOSE WORDS TODAY
RESONATE NOT ONLY WITH DA BRAGG
AND THE CHIEF OF POLICE AND THE
MAYOR OF THIS TOWN, BUT EVERY D
IN THIS COUNTRY AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY FOR THOSE OF US THA
WANT BILL REFORM, EVERY
LEGISLATOR IN ALBANY SHOULD HAV
TO LIT LISTEN TO WHAT THIS WOMA
SAID TODAY.
NO WIFE OR MOM SHOULD EVER HAVE
TO SAY THOSE THINGS AND